il fallait la grandeur d'une cathédrale
le silence pour un dernier hommage à une
fille d'ici sa mère est venu de l'yonne
son père de l'aube soutenu par une
centaine de personnes quelques badauds
des connaissances de sophie tous touchés
par le drame
ça prend à coeur et c'est un événement
qui est cruel et qui j'espère sera sera
puni à la hauteur de
de ses actes
diabolique on peut même pas imaginer on
peut pas se mettre à leur place et c'est
impossible
très choqué très choqués les très triste
parce que bon on s'y attend pas et de
deux c'est vrai que monique robin quand
la cérémonie débute les proches à la
tribune lui adresse un dernier message
décédé le 20 septembre 2010 est sous les
coups de ses employeurs c'est la
dernière page d'un feuilleton médiatique
de neuf mois entre le moment où ou la
fère s'est déclaré et puis là
aujourd'hui c'est laisser glisser par m
passer à temps très long il ya eu le
corps n'avait pas été rapatriés en
france tout de suite il y avait la tente
du procès et ses excès de rage et dire c
c'était excessivement longs sophie
lyonnais sera inhumé dans l'intimité au
cimetière de sens une partie de sa
famille
ils reposent déjà